did you hear about what happened with
mcafee
john mcafee yeah that was i i saw it
come out live last night on bloomberg
can you put up his tweet so i
interviewed the guy uh i don't know do
we have a video what happened when i
interviewed the guy or no
not readily available if you can if you
can find it so i interviewed john
in 2016. i go to his place when i'm
interviewing the guy you know
you've heard that we've heard the story
but yeah that's really yeah i mean he is
like you know your cell phone is built
to spy on you
the cell phone is built to spawn
everything you're doing that's why i
don't use the regular cell phone that
everybody else uses while i'm doing the
interview in the middle of the interview
a guy knocks on the door kai if you just
kind of go through it
is it just click on it see where it is i
mean somebody just fast forward a little
bit to see
uh you should see what happens
i think it's 43 minutes i think you're
ahead of it
go back go back go back go back go back
okay so can you do me a favor put your
finger on the put put the mouse
on that and go there you go go back a
little bit right there click on it and
get the audio
audio and i know the routes that people
take
um if i want to get to um to ecuador
from hong kong the last country in the
world i'd go through is russia you've
got
50 different options by the way look at
the gunners quite small
he's ready he's got a smoking cigarettes
um russia
so um so i you know
it's hard for me to say is it good
is it bad i don't have all the facts and
neither do you and deposit it so
extremely paranoid yet obviously that
happens in every interview daniel always
takes a gun out you know yeah knocks on
the door but the guy was so paranoid you
know as texans
first time ever i went to an interview
where the guy who
greets me he says hey patrick thank you
for coming out just so you know we got
five prostitutes upstairs if you want to
go before you start the interview i'm
like you know what thank you for the
offer i appreciate that mighty generous
of you
yeah you know hey you know what i'm like
if you want to just like smile happy
ending mario and luis were over there
i'm like you know maybe you ask mario
and louise and they're like no no we're
okay thank you for your hospitality
and there's like m16s ak-47s guns
literally sitting everywhere like
something's up with this he's like a
scarface type of uh
anti-virus software guru extremely
extremely paranoid
so inside the weeds and find out how
to the the extent to which we're being
spied on it's gonna freak you out
i mean i look i won't even get in a
volvo anymore i'm like oh no no no no no
the chinese own it i don't wanna i don't
wanna be
like i don't wanna know that i'm being
spied on ah
you have to realize who this guy worked
for i mean mcafee before
uh starting mcafee he was like a genius
working on what is a client or perk
which one was it he was working at kai
remember where he was working at he was
working at some
uh mcafee was an employee as a
programmer at by nasa's
institute for space studies from 68 to
for the apollo program and from there he
went to univac as a software designer
and later to xerox
as an operating system architect in 78
he joined computer science corporation
as a software consultant he worked for
consulting for booze
allen hamilton which you know who worked
for bruce allen hamilton from 80 to 82
and then from 80 while employed at
lockheed mcafee received a copy of brain
the first computer virus for the pc and
began developing software to come back
combat viruses
and then it becomes what it is he sells
it for 100 million dollars it's now
worth 10 20 billion dollars he sold only
400 million dollars
and then he sends this tweet put this
tweet up put this tweet up he sends this
tweet
uh uh uh in the tweet he says this this
is november 30th 2019 says getting
subtle messages from us officials saying
in fact we're coming for you mcafee
we're going to kill yourself obviously
kill you
i got a tattoo today just in case if i
suicide myself i did and i was wack
check my right arm boom i mean this is
just a little bit weird when you see
some of this stuff
this is not a conspiracy theory
you know this is just here's a guy
that's saying
i would never take my life he sends a
tweet right before go back to his last
recent tweets he sent a tweet prior to
that
go up a little bit go up a little bit
june 16. let me see what's this
june 16. uh the u.s believes i have a
hidden crypto i wish i did but it has
dissolved through the hands of many team
mcafee
your bullets not required my remaining
assets are all seized my friends
evaporated through fear of association i
have nothing yet i regret nothing keep
going up
happy father's day great what does he
say nothing in a democracy power is not
uh
power is given not taken but it is still
power love compassion caring here
have to no use for it but it is fuel for
greed hostility jealousy all power
corrupts take care of which powers
you allow democracy to wield look it's a
little strange
it's a little strange for him to what's
his but along the lines of
of the subject of censorship i mean he
could be right here with us talking
about it
if he wasn't not with us anymore exactly
so i don't i don't know look
uh i get the idea of uh
trying to like when you're when you're a
parent and you're raising kids you want
to have the right influence on your kids
and sometimes you will as a parent
try to keep a kid away from your uh uh
what do you call it your kid because god
forbid maybe a bad habit
maybe a cousin who's an addict and
you're like listen we don't want to go
party and hang out with that kid because
i don't like you to pick up bad habits
but there is
that and then there is you can watch
that
you can't watch this you can't read this
you can't do that i mean it's like
come on buddy it's getting a little too
much right now you're gonna give it a
positive argument and then you wonder
why
you wake up 10 years later and you're
like why is my kid so rebellious
yeah you know who i love to interview i
love to interview people who completely
disagree with me
i love interviewing people who
completely disagree did he agree or
disagree
he was he was all over the place by the
way a lot of the stuff that he said in
the interview
came true a lot of this stuff on what he
said about facebook
and that wasn't 16. yeah a lot of the
stuff that he said came true at the time
people would have called him cuckoo
conspiracy theorists
but a lot of the stuff that he said came
true such as what i mean you
know the fact that uh keep your eyes uh
this whole model of ads and what
facebook what they're doing they're
reading you they're studying you all
they're trying to do is all the
analytics take the systems they're given
to the government that's how
you see that that commercial it is so
powerful that apple commercial
where the guy ends up you know in his
apartment with a zillion
people and then he will say this and
then he hits the privacy yeah he's like
you can't follow me anymore that is a
powerful commercial you're right
yeah i've like i've started to take the
extra few seconds to say
you know i'm on a website looking for
information i'm always doing data
research always writing
do you accept all cookies and i've
started taking the time to go no i
don't yeah well let me ask you pat since
you've you've literally sat down with
this guy mcafee yeah and he's
let's just say had some ups and downs in
his life but over the over the last
by the way let's qualify him he's a very
weird guy
totally that has to be qualified this is
not a he's a very very weird guy yeah
but he's obviously a genius he's a
genius but
extremely many geniuses are eccentric do
you know why he married his wife have
you heard him
tell the story why he murdered his wife
no but was that with or without the
prostitutes
the prostitute the wife was a prostitute
you know why he murdered his wife
no she said he said he gave the best oh
yeah so he's like okay that because of
that i decided and that's what he says
in the documentary so
we have to know that this is a very very
strange guy
but go ahead no here's my question dude
over the last
i'm not talking about all the great
things he did in his 30s and 40s in the
genius i'm talking about
when there's smoke there's fire just
look at his resume over the last five
years or so since you've done this
interview
right so number one he died in a spanish
jail in spain year old uh
stomping grounds uh where he was
extradited to face federal charges so
number one he wasn't even in america
i think when you interviewed him where
was where was he even living in that
nashville tennis uh two hours of
saturday night but wasn't he living in
south america
he was all over he was all over the
place he skipped paying taxes
apparently uh um from 2014 to 2018 so
seven years ago
he was involved in this pump and dump
scheme uh with crypto
that only made him a couple million
dollars when you're worth over 100
million dollars and now you're trying to
like
do a pump and dumpster to make a couple
million 100 million yeah
exactly so when you were there worth 100
million if not more
and now you're scheming and plotting to
make a couple million
that's a telltale sign like things
aren't working out it's so good
no financially he's not like yours is
not cheap so paranoid is not a cheap
lifestyle
if you're everywhere and if you've got
bodyguards around you and all this
ammunition for the points of schizo he's
a little bit on that side so my question
is are you surprised by
this it's obviously unfortunately
surprising that he tweets i would never
whack him i'm surprised that he's at
age 75 found dead of suicide i'm
surprised by that
i'm surprised by that because you know
if you were ever going to take your life
you've done so much drugs that at any
point you could have when you're on
drugs
you don't you don't think reasonably
you're like okay it's not worth you so
he's had plenty of chances to take his
own life yes now he's in jail has he
ever been in jail before like
i arrested one time because he was
accused of killing his neighbor for
feeding his dogs with poison and his dog
died and he found his dog
dead in the back because the dog would
bark and the neighbor who retired was a
millionaire seduced
i just want to retire and he throws the
meat over his dog eats and dies he comes
and kills the guy
so mcafee ends up running they're
chasing him they get so he's done that's
when he was in south america
he's easy here look rest in peace john
mcafee i think
whether whether you want to take the
good the bad the ugly he
was an eccentric character that
definitely influenced a lot of people
and it's just a sad ending to a pretty
you know inspiring entrepreneur type
story just with a very sad
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye